it's been called the worst flooding to
hit india's northeastern assam state the
rain may have stopped now but the flood
waters are still here inundating large
areas of the region many have lost
everything unsure of how or where they
will rebuild their lives
one month has passed since we started
living here and our fields and crops
have submerged in water our house is
inundated now this road has become our
home
more than 200 people have died and
millions have been displaced by the
severe floods that swept across india's
northeast region and neighboring
bangladesh medical teams are still
trying to reach affected areas they say
many are now at risk of contracting
water-borne diseases regarding
post-flood management there are many
issues like
acute gastroenteritis
then fever
many cases has been admitted at various
hospitals
every year heavy monsoon rains cause
rivers to flood but this year was worse
than ever as a some and neighboring
megalia state received more rain than
average the eroding riverbanks failed to
hold the excess water resulting in
floods and landslides like this one in
manipur state
and worsening the situation in
bangladesh which shares common rivers
with india officials say dredging is the
only way to prevent floods like these
last week bangladesh's prime minister
proposed a joint river dredging project
with india to help the region
but for those who have already lost
their loved ones and their livelihoods a
solution can't come soon enough
kara legge al jazeera